it cannot continue like this we cannot
accept that hundreds of people die when
trying to cross the sea to Europe human
tragedy continues to unfold in the
Mediterranean Sea which has become a
mass graveyard for migrants an estimated
900 people were aboard a boat that
capsized off the coast of Libya on
Saturday April 18th only 28 people
survived what a UN official described as
the worst massacre ever seen in the
Mediterranean just two days later two
more incidents of boats capsized and
took place off the coasts of Greece and
Italy the Mediterranean Sea is the
deadliest crossing in the world last
year 218 thousand people crossed the
Mediterranean by sea 3,500 of them died
according to the UN so far this year
more than 1,600 migrants have died
trying to cross the Mediterranean
that's a tenfold increase from the death
toll at the same time last year and we
haven't even reached the peak migration
months so why are migrants risking
everything to make this perilous trip to
Europe many of them consider the
dangerous journey at sea to be less
harsh than the realities they're fleeing
in their home countries civil wars in
Libya and Syria the siege on Gaza famine
across the Horn of Africa and droughts
in the Sahel are driving people to
search for safety and Economic
Opportunity in Europe smugglers have
capitalized on the desperation of these
migrants charging up to $8,000 for the
journey on water often makeshift vessels
that lack navigation systems Italy and
in particular the island of Lampedusa is
the main destination of migrants
traveling across the sea given its
proximity to North Africa last year
170,000 refugees from Africa and the
Middle East entered Europe through Italy
according to the UN so what is Europe
doing about this plight of migrants
dying to get to its shores Italy used to
run a search and rescue operation
but last year handed it over to the EU
two domestic political pressure and high
costs since then the EU has run a much
smaller and cheaper operation the logic
being that less rescue options would
deter would-be migrants from daring to
make the voyage clearly that hasn't
worked but the recent disasters at sea
seem to be a wake-up call for European
leaders who convened an emergency
meeting in Luxembourg on Monday this
week they came up with a ten-point
proposal to be voted on later that would
double the size of Mediterranean rescue
operations and launch military
operations against smugglers in Libya
but even if approved they're still
dealing with a small budget that may not
be enough to tackle a growing problem
that extends far beyond Europe is it
time fortress Europe uses its
immigration restrictions so that no one
ever considers risking their lives to
make this journey what do you think
should be done